tink can your favorite dog
can you can you be random can you be
random no seriously can you be random
I mean random this means you have no aim
you have no Direction there's no rule
there's no method sounds like college
student whatever but seriously can you
be random I mean because sometimes you
think you're being random when in
reality there's actually a pattern that
you don't realize is going on let me
show you I have six foxes and in this
game inspired by Richard Wiseman
we're going to start on the green box so
put your finger there and when I say
move you can go right you can go down
you can go up and you can go left you
just can't go diagonal and no matter how
random you think you're being you're
always going to end up back on the pink
square don't believe me let's test this
out all right ready move one so either
here now or here so we can get rid of
that guy right there we ready for the
rest and move move move move move move
move and move cool then get rid of that
guy
round two and move move move move move
that guy's gone huh
move move move move that guy right
gone now just move one more time pink
square touch it a pink square aren't you
you are I told you you're going to touch
the pink square I told you this at the
beginning we had this conversation sorry
a my minor ear and not so much I just
gave you the illusion of choice but in
reality I limited your options so you
take what I wanted let me show you what
I mean
okay let's go back to the beginning of
the trick which is actually a math
problem so we started out here and your
first move was either here or here and
then I asked you to move eight times but
from either this space or this space
it's actually impossible for you to move
eight times and get to this space don't
believe me try it yourself in fact four
moves won't get you there and an even
larger number like 16 that won't get you
there either wait a minute
what does this mean about life what the
heck man what I'm going to have a crisis
now like what does this mean seriously I
wonder how much of life is actually like
this I mean I think I'm being random I
think I'm being unpredictable and really
I'm just following the pattern
seriously